you okay not okay it's so different than
the person that I married I just can't
in a teaser for next week's episode of
the Kardashians Kim Kardashian was seen
breaking down in front of her sister
Chloe over her ex-husband Kanye West
that's who I loved and that's who I
remember
I'll do anything to get that person back
Kim and Kanye finalized their divorce in
March 2022 after being married for six
years the former couple began dating in
2011 and shared four children together
but it's been no secret that things have
been turbulent between the pair with the
rapper publicly engaging in online
attacks against Kim her family and
former boyfriend Pete Davidson I am the
one
being accused for so many things and
blamed for so many things and it really
really is hurtful and it sucks earlier
this season the Skins founder opened up
about Kanye's erratic behavior and how
she was done protecting him they used to
run around and call everyone behind us
back and be like it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay don't worry just give him
another chance well that's why you got
divorced because you can't do that to
yourself I just don't have that energy
no